What do I think about the whole body MRIs?
That do not use code trash. I think you're talking about the Pruduvo
System so the Pruduvo system that's what I had done the last thing I had done was the Pruduvo scan
I think they're great. So I think there's huge benefit to them
You know, there's the MRIs without code. There's no contrast to use the MRIs without contrast are
You know considered fairly not invasive though. There's some alternative practitioners say well
You're still dealing with a very high magnetic field that could mess up your electrical system and such, but certainly the
They
are less invasive than radiation
So it was from Simon bed. It only cost $600. So I don't think it was the Pruduvo. I could email you one of the articles
Yeah, I don't know. There may be some other systems that are coming out of the market. So my last one I did was
About three years ago or something like that. So
Yeah
They could be a good
indication like any test, you know, no test is perfect
So you could say oh, I did a PET scan and it was all clean. So I don't have to you know
You don't do anything anymore
And you know, it could not be picking up something that is just too small for it to pick up or
You could you do a PET scan and it shows a hotspot and it's and it's a
You know a pseudo tumor where it's a pseudo or large, but that is
That is not correct. So no test is is perfect. So
If you just keep that in mind and you go, okay, well, I'm gonna do you know, trying to do things as less and basic as possible
Then that's a good thing to do. I do think so that you know, if you do something you have to plan on
Okay, if if I get a use this to monitor my you know cancer or lack thereof
Then you keep doing the same test from the same place
That's always beneficial
Whether even if you do a CT scan or a PET scan, it's always best to go back to the same place if possible
Because you're gonna have a greater degree of accuracy to measure apples to apples
In new comparisons
so
You know, I'm not sure of the system that you're talking about and how accurate it is to see
Different cancers if it's the Pradovo at least they touted the information that's out there
the studies that they
Refer to that it's as accurate as a PET scan
With no invasiveness so
So it it gives you the contrast or it's not just giving you hotspots like a PET scan. It's giving you
visual
Acuity of different organs and tissues, so I think there's benefit to that. So I'm not sure about the exact machine you're talking about but
If they if they show confidence is in their studies about
Cancer in what size that they can measure cancer as to go forward with for that price can be very beneficial
Now a lot of some of those alternative things are not covered by insurer, so
But at $650 that might be your gold payment on a regular PET scan and then a PET scan is obviously ready
You shouldn't you don't want to be doing that too often